(light electronic music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History,
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is John Heilbron,
Emeritus Professor of History
and History of Science at
Berkeley who is this year's
Hitchcock Professor at Berkeley.
Professor Heilbron
created the Office for the
History of Science and Technology
during his 30 year tenure at Berkeley.
He was the class of 1936
Professor of History
and the History of Science and also served
as Vice Chancellor and
Chair of the Berkeley
Division of the Academic Sen.
Since his retirement, professor Heilbron
has been a visiting
professor at UC Berkeley,
Oxford University and Yale University.
He is honorary fellow of Worcester,
Worcester College Oxford
and now lives in England.
John, welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised across
the bay in San Francisco.
- And looking back, how do you think
your parents shaped your
thinking about the world?
- Well I should say almost
completely when young.
My father was very much
involved in civic life.
He was an attorney, but he
served on the California,
well served on, he headed
the board of trustees
of the California state
colleges, now state universities.
So I grew up in a family in which,
what the merits and
peccadillos of professors
were discussed at dinner.
- And I would assume it was a home
with a book lined library?
- Yes, yes.
- And the topics at the
dinner table in addition
to the difficulties of
dealing with faculty included?
- Well, almost anything.
My father also was very active
in the World Affairs Council
of Northern California of which
he was its president for a time.
And what else?
He was a leading figure
in the Jewish community.
And so,
almost anything could turn
up at the dinner table.
- Did you have any
teachers as a young person,
I know you went to Lowell High School,
that kind of influenced you
in the direction of science?
- I don't think so.
Lowell was and is a very
good general high school,
so one took languages
and history and science,
but I didn't concentrate
on anything in particular.
Mathematics, I did concentrate
on mathematics I suppose
and then I took all that was offered,
but otherwise no, except I can
say that my physics teacher
was so bad that he,
or she I think it was,
inspired me with a desire
to learn how anybody
or any subject so empty
could have built an atomic bomb,
or I should have been under,
should have supplied the information
for building such a weapon.
So like many other people influenced by,
young people influenced by the standing
of the brilliant young physicists
in song and literature,
I went into physics and studied
physics at the university.
And it wasn't because of any
aptitude or any inspiration
that I received in high school.
- So you saw physics as a
heroic discipline basically?
- Oh yeah, I started in 1951.
And still physicists were
bathed in this glow of glory.
And it was a hard subject,
so people who wanted
mental exercise also
drifted in that direction.
- And this would have been at the height
of the legitimacy of science
in the United States probably.
- Well I didn't know it,
but of course during my
undergraduate years, the fight
over the National Science
Foundation took place.
The AEC got involved or had been,
stayed involved and all sorts of things,
the Office of Naval
Research was supporting
so-called non-mission
oriented research everywhere.
Yeah, but I didn't know
a thing about that.
- And you actually came to Berkeley,
so you just went across the bridge.
- Just across the bridge.
- And what was Berkeley like then?
- Well when I started it was still
full of veterans on the GI bill.
So there was a certain maturity,
or lack of it depending
on which set of veterans
you happen to, and they were,
by and large, intent upon
moving forward their careers
because of course they were older.
But they also had a lot of school spirit
so they filled the football
stadium, and so on.
It was quite, I think,
useful to have this older crowd around.
Then they disappeared
by the time I graduated.
But I still feel from what my
father and mother, who were
also Berkeley graduates
told me about their time
that it wasn't so different.
It was of course in the 50s
where students were relatively docile.
- And Berkeley at that time really lacked
the multi-cultural dimension that it.
- I, well multi-cultural,
certainly it's not as varied as it is now.
But the Asian community, San
Francisco Asian community
was full, the university had a great many
students from the San
Francisco Asian community
many of whom I knew from high school
because Lowell, even then,
was largely, though not
yet a majority, Asians.
So,
but the groups kept, to
some extent, separate.
I did lose track of many of these friends,
which I regretted.
- You majored in physics.
- [John] Yes.
- And what was the physics
department like then,
because the titans were
walking through the doors.
They had been here or were still here.
- Yes, when I started graduate school
in physics here, Ernest Lawrence was still
among the living.
McMillan, Alvarez,
Seaborg, they were all around.
But I was too dumb really to know it.
- You should have taken
history of science.
- I really should have done,
because I never set eyes on Lawrence,
which is a shame because
I wrote a book about him.
I did gradually understand
the importance of Alvarez
and company when it came time
to choose a thesis advisor.
But no, although there was a portrait
of Lawrence hanging in the library,
which did give some
hagiographical slant to things.
At least to the undergraduates
and beginning graduate students,
the glory that was
Berkeley was not trumpeted.
- And so at what point,
before graduation as an undergraduate
or after did you move to
the history of science?
Did you go to gradate
school in the sciences also?
- [John] Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, I was a very slow learner.
No, I was in graduate school in physics
for three or four years
when I finally decided,
I was working on a dissertation in fact
when I decided that that really was not
what I wanted to do.
And so I went down to
the history department,
I'd always been interested
in medieval history.
I went down to the history department
to ask whether they would have me.
I was referred to a medievalist,
and he patted me on the
head, almost literally,
in an avuncular way and he said son,
go back and finish your degree,
the country needs physicists
it does need medievalists.
- Oh dear.
- Which was certainly true.
And so I went back doing work more,
this medievalist neglected to tell me
there was a person named Thomas Kuhn
just arrived on the faculty
who was fresh from Harvard
and an historian of science,
who was desperate for students.
So eventually I came to
know Kuhn and I changed.
- I'm a little curious
about your thought processes
in making the switch before
you found the place in history
was, what did you see about yourself
and the work that you were doing,
or was it the issue area,
namely you thought it was
more important to put science
in the context of history?
- I wish I could say that, but in fact,
as I worked into my dissertation topic
I realized I'd have to
know more mathematics,
quite a bit more mathematics to do it.
And so I thought as long
as I was going to retool,
why don't I do it in something
that interested me more?
Not to save society,
not because I felt that
physics was going the wrong direction,
no big issue at all.
Just simple desire to follow
what appeared to me to be my interest
and perhaps a slightly stronger
suit than I had in physics.
- Tell me about Kuhn because I know when,
when the 60s came around I was here
in graduate school,
his work was considered
so very important in understanding
scientific revolutions.
How was he as a teacher and
what was his influence on you?
- Well he was a terrific
teacher if you happened
to find something that worked in well
with the structure of
scientific revolution.
And I was lucky in finding
such a vein early on.
And so he was, for a
time, much more interested
in my work than I was, and
that's wonderful for a beginner.
And so enthusiasm,
good ideas about where to look for things,
a pretty general ignorance about history.
- He had.
- Yeah, he had.
- He had started in physics too, right?
- Well he had done more than start,
he got through his PhD in physics
and then he got caught
up in this Conant program
at Harvard to teach undergraduates the,
what do they call it, the
tactics and strategy of science.
Which meant in effect, exposing
them to what they called
case studies of the history of science,
but of past science,
science so remote that even
a Harvard undergraduate
could understand it.
And so from that, people
were to understand
how difficult it is to arrive at usable,
effective scientific theories
and would then cheerfully pay their taxes
to support science during what was then,
when Conant began to plan,
the beginning of the Cold War.
- Now, and what was the
topic of your dissertation
that interested Kuhn?
- Oh actually it wasn't my dissertation.
- Oh it was what you
were interested in, okay.
- No it was the first set of papers
I wrote for him as a student.
They had to do with early electricity,
electricity primarily in the 18th century.
And it happened that the
development of the subject
fit his ideas fairly well.
And so he was quite interested.
My thesis was on the
history of atomic models,
20th century quantum theory
and things like that,
which was an outgrowth of a project
that he headed up and I participated in
to interview quantum
physicists and to collect their
documents, letters, records, papers.
- And just in passing,
what department was he in?
Was he in philosophy or he was in history?
- He was half, he began half in history
and half in philosophy.
But then when it came time
for the tenure decision,
He became 100% in history.
- I see, okay.
Let's talk a little about doing history
and then the history of science.
What do you see as the skills involved
in doing the work that you do?
- Other than patience?
- Well yeah, patience, I was
gonna ask you about that.
- Well that is one, just to
revert to Kuhn for a minute,
that's one of the things that
he lacked as an historian.
He didn't have the
metabolism of an historian.
Sluggish.
- (laughing) Patience is better.
- Patience is perhaps better.
And the idea of,
reading lots of documents,
many of which are going
to yield very little was
not his notion of good fun.
- So but what else?
Students watching this program,
patience okay, if you
don't have it don't do it.
- Well I think you need
a funny combination
of patience and boldness.
So that you have to impose
your structure on the world.
Reading historical
documents does not give you
history as you know.
And you need to have
principles for selection
and for organization which naturally means
you're going to leave things out.
However, a third point, you have to have
respect for the evidence.
And some of the things
that are written now,
and no doubt were always written,
but of which I'm
particularly conscious now,
have some good ideas
and no doubt the writer
tries to impose upon the material,
but the way of arguing, the
way of treating evidence,
respect for the testimony of
the past, is often lacking.
So I would say to anybody out
there who might be listening,
common sense way of arguing is far better
often than these fancy
methods that are dreamt up
in order to limit the materials to suit
a certain point of view.
So Harry, if you're
going to be an historian,
you must cultivate
patience, you must cultivate
respect for the sources,
and by respect I mean not only taking them
at face value, insofar as you can,
but also paying attention to what others
have written about the subject.
I think that too many beginners think that
they should begin with the archives,
with the first piece of
paper that was written
on some such subject.
They early learn that that's not possible,
then they go to imposing their will.
But you have to read
good secondary writers
and you have to know their points of view,
so as to be able to judge them.
But we too, despite what Kuhn said,
we too, we historians, we
build upon our predecessors.
- In listening to your
lectures and looking
at some of your books,
I think when one gets
into science there's really
two important things that stand out.
One, in your lectures,
to in a way be a cosmopolitan yourself,
be well-versed in languages
and to essentially play
off the conversation
in different parts of the world
during an historical period.
Is that fair?
- Yeah, this is one of the
old slogans in history.
You're able to converse with
whatever mind you choose
from the past, well
that's a little bit bold.
But certainly if you know
the language of this person,
then you can enter into
some kind of relationship.
Perhaps a bit of a necro,
a bit of necromancy is,
is required, but that's one of
the great treats of history.
It frees you from time and place.
- And to really get into the head
of the principle you're looking at.
Because on the one hand
he may be a scientist
but on the other hand he
may think he's god basically
or a prophet as you discussed
in yesterday's lecture.
- Yes, though I would not
presume to get into the mind
of anyone who thought himself god.
But in fact, one has
to, of course construct
the persona of this person
with whom you are conversing.
And you're not climbing into his head
and thinking his thoughts.
You are constructing from what
remains there may be, which are not
necessarily only literary.
What sort of paintings
did this person like,
what sort of music?
And so on.
But you are constructing
an artificial person,
and your success depends
upon, very similar to,
how you are able to make
use of what is known
in order to construct a plausible picture.
A bit like a novelist but
you're more constrained.
- And also in the history of science,
it's very clear in looking at your work,
you really have to understand
the technical issues,
the struggle with ideas in the science
that the figure you're
writing about was involved in.
- It's best to be able to do that, yes.
- Not absolutely required, yes.
But also then to be able
to write about it clearly.
- Yeah.
- Because you may put down the formulas,
but in fact you have to explicate
because the people who may
be your primary readers
are not necessarily
scientifically trained.
- Well you're absolutely right,
you have your finger on a
big problem which gets more
difficult as the science you review
comes closer to the present
and gets more difficult.
That's why I mentioned in
Harvard case studies method,
the idea was to use old dead science
because it was qualitative
and didn't make such
great demands upon the students.
So, right, how then to inform people,
in an interesting way, about
what you have found out
about some persons who science,
they may need some background
to understand? Yeah.
- In looking at your
publications,
there are three biographies
of scientists in different periods.
Or at least of the ones
that I sort of looked at.
I'm trying to think, Max Planck,
Lawrence.
- [John] An Englishman named Mosley.
- And Mosley, yeah.
And so,
was it a common set of problems in all,
in digging in and coming to understanding?
They had very different life stories
and they lived in very different eras.
- Well partly opportunism.
So in the case of Mosley
I found a big chunk
of letters that nobody knew existed,
and that was a lot of fun.
I tracked them down in an old Saxon house
way out in the country in England.
Planck was something the same,
I by chance happened to find out,
well actually another
project I was working on
found out that although Planck's own home
and his papers had been
destroyed by the US Army
Air Force during the war,
second world war, there
were great quantities
of the letters he had
written that had been
preserved by people like Einstein
and Bohr and von Laue and so forth.
So, that made another
set of material that
nobody had worked up before
and as for the third one, Lawrence,
that had to do once
again with circumstances
that made it opportune,
reasonable to tackle
Lawrence at the time.
So I cannot claim any
organic unity to that work.
In 10 years time if
I'm asked to reminisce,
I'll probably construct,
I will have constructed
some line that ties them all together.
But you can take it from
me that there is none.
- There is none.
- Except that I do like
the genre biography.
And I'm engaged in a biography right now
which is about a guy who
couldn't be more different
than any of those three or
from myself, for that matter.
An Italian who lived from 1663 to 1729.
And who to me is very interesting
because he was an expert
at so many things.
- And who do you see as
your primary audience
as an historian of science?
I mean I know that you
probably want to reach
a wider audience than either
historians or scientists,
but what is the answer here?
- I've changed of course, over the years.
When I began I felt, as do many beginners,
rightly, they should write for those
who are gonna judge them.
But gradually I have tried
to reach wider audiences
and my test for that is simple.
Does my conversation about
these subjects interest anybody?
And if the answer is no, I
realize that I'm probably
not going to succeed
in attracting a readership.
I don't want a great big readership,
but I would like to be able to
say that at least some
of my work has interested
and diverted, and maybe
possibly instructed
more than a handful of people.
- I'm curious about this
focus on personality
in these three biographies.
Do you see that as a way to
draw people in to elevating
consciousness about the problems
in the history of science?
Because it's fascinating.
In the case of Mosley, just
zipping through the book,
the whole idea that he died so young.
- [John] A biographer's delight.
- Yeah, you could make a romantic
40s movie out of his life.
- You could.
Well yes, it does enable
you to draw people in
with some kind of an obvious human hook.
It also provides a chronology ready-made,
and provides a selection
process ready-made.
So in a way biography is one
of the easiest of genres.
Though I think you do
need a little bit of a
novelist's touch to create the persona.
- Was doing the work on
Lawrence in the Lawrence Lab
easier or harder?
I mean obviously you were
here, you knew many of the
principles who were still living.
But the material was all here.
So what, was there any particular
intellectual problem set
that you had to deal with
as you got into this material?
- Well a little bit,
but if I can revise the
question a little bit.
- [Harry] Oh please do, please.
- Although all the material about,
virtually all the material
about the laboratory was here,
my interest also had to do
with visitors to the lab.
And so I read a lot of letters
from visitors back to
their home countries,
which required visiting archives abroad.
And the only reason I mention that is that
one of the, if the book has any strengths,
one of them is that the laboratory is seen
not only through the eyes
of those who worked here,
but also through the eyes of visitors,
some of whom were not as
ecstatic about the way
things were done as were the
cronies of Lawrence.
- And Lawrence as a figure was
a very colorful guy, an entrepreneur,
and,
that dimension of his career stands out
as much as his science I think.
- Oh yeah.
The 30s which we're talking about,
during the 30s, Lawrence
changed quite a bit.
So one of the interesting features,
or one of the interesting
story lines in this history
is to show how Lawrence
began as a sort of comrade
of the senior students in the laboratory.
Gradually as the search for money and the,
his association with the
people who could provide it,
turned him to the right,
well he developed.
With consequences that we
try to point out in the book.
I say we because I had a co-author.
We must acknowledge Robert Seidel.
- And is that the Seidel
who worked with Oppenheimer?
- No he was a graduate student of mine.
- Oh he was a graduate student, okay.
You did a book, a very
well-received book which won
the Pfizer Prize called
The Sun in the Church:
Cathedrals as Solar Observatories.
How did you wind up doing that?
It sounds utterly fascinating
because it points to a link
between science and
religion that the popular
notions are just wrong about.
- Well this was the greatest
research project I ever had.
Because, I didn't have to be
to the research site, as it were,
which were these
cathedrals which served as
solar observatories until noon.
(laughing)
After my deep observation,
I had to adjourn to the (foreign language)
around the corner to,
what shall I say, digest
my research material.
There again I cannot claim
that I had gone around
searching for a topic
that would illuminate
the connections between
religion and science,
but rather tripped over
one of these long lines
embedded in the pavement
of a cathedralist,
well it's not a cathedral.
Let's see, where was it?
At some San Pietro in
Bologna, a cathedral.
Which,
runs for about 250 feet.
And this line is a noon mark.
So the sun stands directly over
in the meridian of the place
at noon, and from the position
of the sun's image on
this line during different
parts of the year, the sun
is higher in the summer
as the image is closer to the vertical.
You can learn things
about the solar orbit.
And ultimately these
things got to be so precise
you could tie down or answer the question
whether the earth's axis
remains at the same angle
to the plain of its
motion during the year.
This is a very subtle effect
and it was first tied down
at the solar observatory,
I meant these cathedral observatories.
That fascinated me.
Then I tried to study as many
as I could find,
which did contribute to astronomy.
And in the process found out
all kinds of things about
the relationship between
astronomy and the Catholic church
in the years after the
condemnation of Galileo.
That turned out to be quite
illuminating to see how,
what was, no matter what
you had to say about it,
no matter which side
of the story you stand,
was a stupid administrative decision.
And so then better administrators
of the next generation
had to figure out how to impose this
prohibition against the
teaching of Copernicanism,
this sun-centered universe.
And the ingenious ways
that administrators found
to look the other way,
and astronomers found
not to incite them.
This I thought was a
minuet which I had seen
performed before.
- [Harry] In many different contexts.
- In many different contexts.
With the consequence
that long, long before
the proscription against
heliocentrism was removed
from the index of prohibitive books,
it was standard to teach
the Copernican astronomy
in Catholic schools, even by the Jesuits.
- And one issue here was
that the church needed
to know exactly when Easter occurred.
So there was an instrumental reason,
among I'm sure many others,
that led them to sort
of wink, sort of.
- Yes, although to establish Easter,
and Easter is a lunar solar holiday.
That means that calendrical
problem associated with it
has to do with bodies
that could just as well
go around the earth, one
of them does, the moon.
And as for whether the
sun goes around the earth
or vice versa, it doesn't matter.
It's only when you get
the planets into the story
that Copernicus is so
much better, clearer.
Anyway, so you didn't have
to go to a new astronomy,
but you has to use astronomers in order
to tie down the parameters
that would give you
the basis for calculating
Easter more exactly.
And astronomers were interested
in the newest astronomy.
So you were having to deal
with people whose interests
would naturally cause
them to pay no attention
to your prohibitions.
Also I should say that the same people who
would be interested in calendrics,
who would be interested in astronomy
whether new or old, are also the guys
whom you would call to repair the church.
Because applied mathematics
included astronomy,
fortification, canalization of rivers,
hydraulics, navigation, astrology,
whatever you want that
applied mathematics,
and they were, of course,
necessary for the upkeep
of the church's fabric, buildings,
and also surveying of domains,
keeping control of the rivers.
One of the most frequent
things that mathematicians
in Italy did in the 17th and 18th century
was to advise various governments
on how to control the rivers.
- You, during your career at Berkeley,
became the Vice Chancellor.
So to a very a important
role on the campus,
namely the top academic officer
and the person who really runs the campus,
you brought
a unique perspective as
a historian of science.
Or did it matter?
So I guess what I'm trying to ask you is,
did being an historian of science,
was that a good thing
to have under your belt
when you undertook the role?
- Well I think that it was useful
in that I could speak out
of both sides of my mouth.
So I have the vocabulary
that enabled me to talk
to at least some scientists
and to some humanists
including historians.
And that was a benefit.
It was a most interesting experience,
and I think if I can
refer back to my interest
in how administrators
in the Catholic church
handled the proscription
we were speaking about a minute ago,
I think that interest arose from my own
academic administrative responsibilities.
And so, that has proved,
that proved useful to me in
other approaches to history.
So I recommend that if you can do it,
take on some kind of administrative role
and find out what other
people really are like.
- So, okay now I want to understand this.
There are two things that stand out
both in your lectures and
here in our conversation,
you have a real sense of whimsy
and then you're now
talking about the limits
of what can be achieved in organizations
because of the way people are,
human nature and people's
interests and so on.
So, did that come from
your study of history?
Or was there a synergy
between those studies
and what you were learning
as an administrator?
- Well I'd like to think there was.
And yes, perhaps there was.
The recognition that,
institutions, though they
may have a single name,
contain a lot of different
disparate elements.
And, if you apply that insight,
which you don't have to
have been an administrator
to have achieved, to the Catholic church,
you don't go around saying
that the church did this,
the church did that.
You know perfectly well
there were Franciscans,
and there were Dominicans, and Jesuits,
and the Vatican and
the cardinals all going
different directions and so forth,
so that the decisions
that it finally reached,
that is the church, the
Catholic church finally reached
were often negotiated ones.
- So an awareness of the
complexity of institutions, yeah.
- And of course, then there
was geographical distances.
- As Vice Chancellor, was
there ever a time where you
sort of concluded that you
were really learning something
about the organization of science
that you had not known as an historian
or had not come across
in your previous work?
- Yes, I think so.
You learn various things
of great importance.
For example, who wrote the memo?
(laughing)
You know, you have a
conversation with somebody
about something that needs to be done,
and you agree what is to be said,
and then the other fellow
goes and writes you
your memo which you then respond to.
So I learned that you can't even tell
from the signature who
had the principle input
into a document, it might
very well be the recipient
and not the sender.
I learned any number of things
which I probably should not disclose.
But one of the things I learned
about was that our faculty,
whose minds are so vast,
they encompass the universe,
are generally unable to understand
the concept of overhead.
And so, one of the most
interesting parts of my job
was trying to explain to
a disbelieving faculty
that they did not own the overhead
recovered by the university,
under research grant.
- We should explain to
our audience when you get,
say a Federal grant, there
is a charge put on the grant
which the university
gets because of its costs
in running the university.
- That's it.
Which, when I was here,
was a little under 50%.
- We just interviewed
Donald Kennedy yesterday
and this topic came up,
so it must be something
dear to the hearts.
Is there, in your role as Vice Chancellor,
what was your biggest
challenge, basically?
Was there one particular problem
that you had to deal with
that stands out in retrospect
or that was a problem
of the particular time
when you were the Vice Chancellor?
- Well I think we had a lot of problems.
But they were, many of them,
of the standard kind that can't
be solved, just ameliorated.
But, they were to some degree intensified
by the fact that during the
four years I was Vice Chancellor
our state budget was
cut regularly each year.
Now that's bad.
But it's not all bad.
Because, if you have to
make deep enough cuts
then you have to make decisions.
And I think that although
that was probably
the toughest thing we had to do,
nonetheless it was in some
since the most creative.
When everything is going very well
and this year you're
incrementally better than you were
last year, you don't go back to anything
like zero based budgeting,
you just let things go.
But if you have to cut,
what I've now forgotten,
but it was something
like an accumulated cut
of 30% of state funds,
then you're talking about
decisions of importance.
And I think that we,
on the whole, navigated fairly
well through that bad time
and were able to, by creative
use of such things as
the retirement incentives,
which enables us to
switch some money about,
managed to get through
without doing real damage
to the program, instructional
and research program
of the university.
- When you have budget
cuts and I'm not talking
about your tenure as Vice Chancellor,
it's often the case that the humanities
suffer more than the other disciplines.
Are we gonna pay a price for that
in the sense that it would
seem as there's more and more
change with science, that the humanities
are more important than ever.
- Well that would be my position.
The question whether the
humanities are more vulnerable
to budget cuts or not,
this is not so easy to say
because the overhead in the sciences,
having to do with laboratories
and so on and so forth,
does in some respects
make it more vulnerable.
When all your money is in
salaries of tenured faculty,
it's hard to say anything without
closing down a department.
If you ever tried to do that around here,
you will know that there are some causes
that are truly hopeless.
So yes, but not perhaps
they're more vulnerable
because they're loaded
here on tenured faculty.
There isn't much you can do
except not to fill vacant slots
which is one of the things that we did.
We just let openings accumulate
and use the salary savings
for programmatic purposes.
But the other question
would be something like
does the growth of the
engineering side of the natural sciences,
engineering applications
of the natural sciences,
and business on the campus threaten
the health of the humanities,
in which I include history.
Well I'm glad to say I'm
not close enough an observer
of what's going on at
Berkeley at the moment
to offer and kind of definitive answer,
but I would think that from
a general point of view,
you could not help but worry.
And one of the problems here I believe
is that the humanities and,
the more humane social sciences
are not sufficiently aggressive.
- Getting back to the history of science
and this whole question of the humanities
and the situation we
find ourselves in today,
why is the history of science
important for science?
- Yes.
Well, I think the history
of science is important
for science in the same way that history
is important for everybody,
for society at large.
And history of science
may be of greater interest
to scientists than the history of Greece
or something like that, but maybe not.
I know lots of scientist
who would far rather read
the history of the middle ages
than of what, the history of
science during the 19th century
which to many of them is as
distant as the middle ages.
But it's history that one
ought to read and ponder
and use to take distance from
one's own immediate position.
And perhaps,
such study might render one less arrogant
and less confident that the solutions
of all time are to be found just right now
by our generation.
A certain amount of
humility is often engendered
by a study of history,
often not to be sure.
But, so I wouldn't say
that the history of science
provided anything in the
grand picture for a scientist
more than history itself,
and maybe general history
would be even more useful.
However, as a pedagogic tool,
I think the history of science
has much to offer that has
not been capitalized upon.
- For example?
- For example the standard
textbook presentation
which tends to be
axiomatic and by principle,
I mean not necessarily formally axiomatic,
but it's arranged in some
sort of logical order,
does not reach all minds.
Some people find it much
easier to digest information
in the same way almost
in which it was found.
And if not that, some
sort of combination of
a wider approach to the subject matter
and the more principled
delivery of knowledge
which is now possible.
And another thing is it
can be psychologically
very encouraging or reassuring
for students to find out
that Galileo or Bohr or
Maxwell didn't come to their
theories in a flash of
genius, but rather worked
very hard on them and faced problems
that were just the same
problems that an undergraduate
today has to struggle with.
I've had some moderate
success in teaching people
quantum mechanics by bringing
them back to the problems
that caused people to invent
it in the first place.
And to show that these
inventors had terrible problems
and sometimes exactly the same problems
that the student today had.
Thermodynamics is another good case
where an historical
approach can be useful.
I don't say it's useful for everything,
but only that it is an unmined source.
- And in a society where
the consequences of science
are greater and greater
every day and we have
to inform out citizenry
about how to think about
science in the public
realm, what you're saying
strikes me as kind of an interesting way
to elevate that general conscious.
- Well that's one thing,
but I'm glad you brought
the matter up in the way you did,
because it allows me to say
I think history of science
is much more important for non-scientists
than for scientists.
And that's one reason I try to write
a little bit more broadly.
- If students were
watching this interview,
how would you advise them
to prepare for the future,
whether as an historian or not?
Is there some lesson that
we can draw here about
understanding
current events, what's
gonna happen down the road,
in light of the kinds
of things you studied?
- Well I'm not gonna set up as guru.
- This is your guru moment.
- No, I,
all I can do is fall back
on platitudes that have
been around since the
time of Cicero, you know?
- [Harry] Since no one is reading Cicero.
- Historia magistra vitae, right?
History tells you, directs you, helps you
understand your predicament
as a human being
and by reviewing the historical record
gives you some idea of the
direction in which you're going,
precautions to take,
opportunities to seize.
It's not an infallible guide.
- But let me make this the final question,
what about policy makers?
In other words, is there a lesson here
for the policy makers who have
to deal with the issues that
are affected by science?
- Of course, and not only just
those affected by science.
We know perfectly well,
we see it dramatically
exposed every day that statesmen,
ignorant of the circumstances,
countries they are pleased to invade.
Not only themselves pay the price
but also everybody else.
Yeah, about that, of
course there is no doubt.
Although the past doesn't
tell you what the future
is gonna be, it can really give you
good indications about what not to do.
- Well on that note
John I want to thank you
for coming back to the
campus and thank you
for taking time to do
this interview with us.
- I thank you, Harry.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(light music)